[Music]
well-off chinese thing
when you go to like the the hick towns
that's when they start fighting for real
in the what what you mean by that did
you say that
did you see the chinese towns
what the [ __ ] what frozen you kiss
your mother with that mouth what's a
chinese hick town
okay i gotta go first no no no no no
what is that i know
i know what hicks are right
yeah i can't believe you said that
wait hang on frozen
i would compare it to like one of the
outlying islands in the philippines like
one of those maybe like those kind of
hicks
because those people are out there
[ __ ] racist [ __ ] look this is this is
the only thing that comes up when i when
i search chinese hick okay it's awesome
i like being a cowboy because you have
that imagery
so there you go bruce is a chinese
student who became a cowboy after moving
to texas for school
frozen is that you
this is a story about fitting in and
what it means to feel american frozen i
can see you as a cowboy you head out to
like alberta you don't have to come here
to the united states just go over to
alberta or manitoba oh you want to do
that out there you want to be a canadian
asian cowboy my name is
alberto
okay
stampede please and i know it's cold
anywhere if you have a ranch right now
let me listen to his accent for a second
my name is bruce and this is untold
america
okay if you were listing that guy on the
phone the last thing you think is he's
asian
this guy's a hick a real actual american
accent there he first came to the states
i didn't have a southern accent
i am from quebec united southwest china
i
learned my southern accent mostly by
watching
dark dynasty
this guy's got a louisiana
texas
thank you carl someone actually got it
frozen means poor asians the ones that
use back alleys as toilets thank you
look man look i'll say this we always
want immigrants to assimilate what is
more assimilating than this can this i
learned my accent from duck dynasty and
those are [ __ ] cages i learned my
accent from toast dynasty down in the
bayou
right aren't they from louisiana uh yeah
they buy you louisiana or georgia maybe
georgia is there a difference
crazy redneck up in here and jeff [ __ ]
with these uh videos
come on
[Applause]
if you're not allowed to be muslim you
might be chinese
he's some [ __ ] they're all george so
he's got a georgia accent that's really
what it is and let me guess brother pro
wrestling if there's anything if they're
sick oh that's gonna be awesome if there
are suicide nets outside of your factory
you might be chinese
if you're building ghost cities and
ruining the global economy
you might be chinese if what you're
making has 28 different names all sold
on amazon you might be the kind of
person good this is great this is if you
the chinese rednecks of comedy tour i
don't watch that in a [ __ ] heartbeat
awesome
if you cook dog you might be an asian
if you've had kfc
five times this week you might be a
[ __ ]
if you're when you eat fried chicken
with with fried rice you might be an
asian if your chicken tenders come with
duck sauce you might be a chinese if you
started a worldwide pandemic to shut
down the entire planet you might be
asian if you realized i just let this
out the lab but i'm going to blame it on
pangolin you might be
if your favorite dumpling is wonton and
not chicken you might be a china
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
w-o-n instead of j-u-a-n
you might be a [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] man oh that was awesome
oh [ __ ] man if your salad is kimchi you
might be a [ __ ]
if your [ __ ] is sideways you might be a
child now let's just race the
stereotypes
oh [ __ ] if you've never seen a black
person you might be a [ __ ]
if your donuts come with sesame seeds it
might
if the location of your homeland is also
a dish that i get at lucky dragon you
might be a [ __ ] i love this this is
my new favorite thing if your president
looks like winnie the pooh you might be
a giant
if i can spell your president's name
with the greek alphabet you might be a
[ __ ] if your factory workers are
still too young to get the vaccine you
might be a [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] if you had first go go ahead i
was about to make up if you ride hondas
instead instead of ford's you might be a
[ __ ] if your force are named after
suicide you might be a child
running your mama's chinese food
restaurant you probably came from china
if they harvest your organs for rich
people you might be a [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] all right come on we got to see
who else he learned it from the way i
could do this for hours don't get me
wrong but i have to see who else
if your richest relative buys a new
house and you have to help take the
wheels off of it
if you go to popular landmarks and do
selfies doing this you might be a
[ __ ]
if you have a global economy depends on
your [ __ ] ports it might be each
other
if your porn involves squids you might
be a [ __ ] if you control 95 of the
world's antibiotics you might be a
[ __ ]
i said i don't want to get you hit for
misinformation i don't give a [ __ ] no no
no no no no
if your grandma's feet are smaller than
a baby's you might be a [ __ ] thank
you connor nice nice
you sell gremlins in a shop
your soup comes with extra bat
okay
um
all right enough all right please please
pro wrestling all right i really want
i really do hope and i also lord for
watching jim cornette
you might not i learned from jim
that inspired bruce to start his own
youtube channel to teach others to speak
he has a youtube channel of course
oh no of course winky
oh no
bruce wang if you want to first swipe
exaggerated and soften clouds how do
people usually respond when they see you
this
uh chinese cowboy with a southern accent
well ma'am they respond poorly they
think i'm making fun of them
i like the ma'am
well ma'am i think they're making fun of
me
by the way guys this gives a new meaning
to the show yellowstone
oh no he gave up the cowboy gimmick oh
yeah now he's a bitcoin bro oh
boo this is way bigger
bro he could have been a big he could
have been a chinese bitcoin cowboy well
yeah but he's not he's all bitcoin man
oh
oh [ __ ] bro
well depending on where they meet me it
gets really interesting
bruce fully immersed himself in cowboy
culture by working but the accent's
wrong for where he is i know dude it's
not even the right southerner he's got a
southern georgia accent in texas
[Music]
this is james and he's my cowboy mentor
he taught me how to rattle what's the
difference between james and him
i keep calling him sifu but he doesn't
like
that word he keeps saying stop using
that luke language have a cattle
first time i talked with bruce over the
phone and see it's different
and of course we also have a mexican
cowboy too there's so many well mexicans
do have cowboys so there's a difference
yeah
they all came from south america
they had told me she was oriental
he was oriental oh boy he's already
using it he was one of them [ __ ]
zipper heads that i shot when i was 18.
i tell you god damn good let me tell you
something i was pissed off and [ __ ]
charlie walked his happy ass right
through my ranch game like the [ __ ] is
this and that song [ __ ] started talking
to me was [ __ ] southern accent i'm
like all right charlie i got you for now
you're cool man but you know just
i'll thank you for now let me tell you
something you zipper [ __ ] i see you
when i'm sleeping and it's raining
outside you're happy has better stay in
the [ __ ] house
you keep that cowboy hat on a hundred
percent of the time when you're on your
way you [ __ ] hear me yeah when i
thought i'd show the [ __ ] sombrero
i'm gonna make a mistake that [ __ ] and
i'm gonna knife your [ __ ] ass like i
did
makes a good point
hobo makes a good point a brown fella
teaching a [ __ ] ways of cowboy dude
i got it everything's amazing this is
this whole video can i say this is this
is the stuff the internet was made for
like this kind of [ __ ] is amazing to me
oh [ __ ] now listen here you could stay
here but i'm not drinking any of your
coca-cola if you offer it or i know i
know what you people do to your
coca-cola you hear me oh silly
low-maiden chorizo that sounds delicious
actually
yeah a clown
a classic cowboy meal lo mane maiden
jodie
classic we normally make we normally
make chili around here but what we're
going to do is mix it up this time with
dog wait what
yeah i got my accent mostly from duck
dynasty jeff foxworthy and kid rock what
he's from detroit
i call this dish
sweetened sour grits oh sweet and sour
sweet and sour grits no
oh boy oh [ __ ] man